hopefully I don't get fired for this hi
I'm fluffy and I have the most
ridiculous work from home or story so I
was sitting working from home as one
does in the middle of a global pandemic
and I needed to use the restroom so I go
over I open the door and I kid you not I
saw 10 like it was their hive or
something or their nest and it was truly
one of the most terrifying things I've
ever seen so obviously I screamed and
called my fiance slammed the door shut
he opened the door and we saw 10 more at
least lofts just falling out of our
vents so we're both freaking out we
realize we have to call the exterminator
because obviously neither of us are
equipped to handle a wasp infestation I
can't use the bathroom I only have one
bathroom in my apartment couldn't use it
so that was a pain it took the
exterminator around two hours to get to
our apartment so he wait for him you
know I'm like I'm doing a little bit
that's why I'm working on my computer
freaking out about these wasps helping
the exterminator gets here he's got all
his supplies ready to bomb out or back
for a week it opens the door and all the
wasps were gone could you not not one
wasp in sight it's it's like we made the
story up so he goes to the roof and
shucks to see if there's a nest up there
and there was no nest so no idea it's
like the tail would disappear and wasps
but it was truly terrifying and that's
my new horror story about the time bunch
of wasps flew into my bathroom my name
is Sean I'm at allit resident here at
BuzzFeed and this is my work from home
Horror Story hopefully I don't get fired
for this working from home has honestly
been great even though most my work
revolves speak in the studio and
shooting content I've been able to do
the same thing here at home I'm super
super grateful however I've also learned
that working at home has its challenges
one of them is that I had to recreate
aniconic Odle for a video Atlas I was
trying to look like this picture to a
team and the last step was getting out
of it and this person had this material
around there just to make it look like a
dress I said on my little photo shoot
area I got you know bed sheets to make
it look like the background I opened up
the window to get natural light and and
I started posing pictures you know
living giving my best life however it's
in the middle of the day and I totally
forgot that when you have a window open
people can come by and watch you so here
I am and then I just ever so slightly
these two cute grandmas that I love to
death were just staring at me thumbs up
you know and I was so shy and I want to
like pie but I couldn't so I just like
and then I went to my window close the
curtains and I was just all red
eventually I went outside with the shirt
on and they were just like oh yeah
I'm just like it's just for video y'all
it's not like that it like sure it is
they give me like this week and I'm like
okay calm down ever since then I made
sure that when I do shoot videos like
now that there is no one outside and I'm
gonna give the grandmas Oh photos
because they're now my number one
supporters hey I'm 10 there's been some
stuff going on in my apartment has
definitely made this quarantine a lot
more interesting so I don't have a whole
lot of experience with paranormal
activity or supernatural occurrences but
it is something I'm very interested in
so something I often find myself
discussing with friends little things
would happen here and there that would
that would creep us out but now that
quarantine got to spending a lot more
time in a crib now I feel like we have
the opportunity to notice things that we
otherwise wouldn't notice for example
something that's been happening that's
really creepy
is in the in the living room of the
apartment there's one big window it has
blind so every evening before we go to
bed I close the blinds and every morning
when I wake up I open the blinds you
know let the sunlight in so that's like
by normal ritual what I've been noticing
recently is that I'll close the blinds
nighttime we go to bed and then when I
come out in the morning they're open
like I did not open them they just open
it's not my fiance we're both asleep so
we were discussing that situation with
the blinds and I kind of jokingly made
the statement like hey you know if
there's any ghosts in hand.he paranormal
stuff going on like knock it off man
you're pissing me off you know I'm
saying so the morning after I said that
I come outside and not only were the
blinds open but there was a hoodie on my
couch and it happened to be my favorite
hoodie it's a Bruce Lee hoodie that I
have the creepy part about that specific
hoodie being on the couch more than the
fact that I didn't put it there and
neither did my fiance is I have a lost
that hoodie weeks ago when quarantine
had just started I did laundry one day
that hoodie was part of the laundry put
in the washing machine and when I went
downstairs to swish stuff to the dryer I
noticed that it wasn't in the washing
machine and I was devastated because
like I said it's my favorite hoodie I've
had it for years
I actually asked to see the security
cameras for the laundry room and I
didn't notice anything like nobody went
in there and messed with the washing
machine so it was really it made those
sense why my hoodie wouldn't be in there
so come outside and
hoody my favorite hoodie is chillin
there on the couch right after I had
like called out this ghost or whatever
the night before I do not even as I'm
telling you this story right now my
camera stopped recording and it's
switched from selfie cam which is on
right now to like the other way it's in
normal so like I said you know nothing
malevolent has really happened anything
has been kind of helpful I don't have to
open blinds it's my favorite hoodie that
I lost being found and it was it was
laying right there and wait for me so
that was really nice got my favorite
hoodie back but it is still kind of
unnerving I don't really know how to
explain these events interesting points